before we get to the chamber part let's
remember what the jurors of inverse trig
functions are so what was the first one
that we learned - yellow sign write the
derivative I'm signing this is okay so
you've got one over a semicircle okay
it's the positive one which makes cos
inverse the same thing but negative yeah
how do you remember which ones which
apart from I just remember because my
memorizing skills are awesome okay I
suppose when you differentiate cause you
get minus sign see different you come
visit yeah okay that works
I like to have the picture of the graphs
in my head okay because you need to know
the graph anyway right there's sign and
there's cuts so one is increasing one is
decreasing that's where you have a
possible bonus room okay and just to
complete the set what's the derivative
of square and also on the bottom it's a
plus because you used the sec square
plus one identity I think we're ten
squared plus one equals the same square
right now you guys know how to
differentiate inverse trig functions you
know how chain rule works so in some
senses kind of don't need to give this
lesson but in my experience there have
been enough little tricks and traps and
unusual things that come out of these
results that it's worth me actually
working through with you okay so let's
just do a simple one what's the
derivative of sine inverse and let's
change the inside function to be x
squared now you guys are certainly now a
chain rule that probably you could start
doing this straight away and you
wouldn't need to do the substitution
okay but just for the sake of it just be
careful let's go ahead and introduce a
new function right so what would you
pick
just x squared right the inside function
okay so over here you get this
derivative so there's one okay I can
rewrite this as T on DX oh sorry
okay so what do I do now what do ya good
so I'm gonna do this one which is just
like this it's just that our side should
change that
so I'm gonna differentiate that okay but
I want to multiply that by 2 u 1 DX so I
get the d use cancelling yes
so there's my 2 X yeah and all I have to
do subsidy back I'll put the 2x back on
the top there no big deal okay now you
tell me where do you think most people
fall down on this where do you think is
the most common error yeah yeah hold on
I'll get to in a sec what were you
saying doesn't people forget to
differentiate this yeah that's that's
one error what is the other one
neutrality yeah okay so we have two
things you want to look out for I think
mr. bokun for most people if they don't
write out the full-on chain rule we use
in X's and that kind of thing okay
they'll go straight from here to this
step but they'll forget to square okay
I'm very very very common so you don't
end up with X to the 4 here you end up
with x squared which is actually what
you meant to have okay all right let's
do another quick one how about the
derivative or tan inverse of the square
root of x okay let's see we can do it
this time without writing it out to form
okay what's the first thing you would
write down
should do the inside of the outside
doesn't really matter which one we do
first let's do the inside shall we
what's the derivative of the screw - XO
1/2 hmm
do I need to write it out over here
bring the power out power reduces okay
so this is one on to read X right okay
now what know here's what I used to have
right but the function is an X it's the
square root of x so therefore it'll be 1
+ just X ok
that is kind of a dime here I can put
them together as one fraction everything
but don't that's fine okay now these are
all simple right but I want to use this
idea and have a think that some of the
results we've looked at before and so
you can shed some light
okay so I want you think back to when we
were doing graphing and we looked at
this function sine inverse of sine X
remember this guy okay now don't let it
out but just mentally get in your head
what a picture of this one is remember
that this inside function is periodic
right so therefore when you take the
whole thing you end up in the periodic
version it's not the one that's just
restricted in a particular domain so the
derivative of this thing okay I want you
to think about I'll give you a few
minutes to get a head start on me I know
we could just say all right that's equal
to X in a certain domain and then
differentiate that and you know what
that is right but I want us to consider
it from this angle in mathematics this
is often the way it is you take one
problem and you look at it from two
different angles and you often get a new
revelation of you know what you
understood before or what do you need to
be the case but you didn't understand
why okay so I'll give you a few minutes
to differentiate that I'll give you a
tip there's a trick involved and I will
come together and see what we get okay